(lively music)
- I've never had Red Vines
or Twizzlers in my life.
- I never really ate Twizzlers because
I was allergic to them and
didn't even know Red Vines
were a thing until pretty recently.
- I'm from Scotland and to
the best of my knowledge
we don't have either of these.
- I appreciate the texture.
It feels kind of cool.
- Oh, no.
- I don't like this.
- It tastes kind of like medicinal.
- It's like play dough meets Robitussin.
- It doesn't taste like a sweet candy.
I don't know why you would eat this.
- This is quite yummy.
- The taste of this one
is way more bearable.
- This one's harder to chew though.
- It tastes kind of
like a muted gummy bear.
- It tastes more fresh.
- I like the second one better.
- I definitely prefer number two.
- I guess I liked Twizzlers
more than Red Vines.
- You just got to do you.
If you like Red Vines,
keep eating Red Vines.
If you like Twizzlers, eat Twizzlers.
I'm going to be sitting
here eating neither,
and that's okay too.